one of my favorites known him for quite
some time um
been covering him ever since i started
covering the nfl back in 2003
and he is fresh off of a remarkable
performance
a remarkable individual and team
performance on sunday night football so
we welcome back here
on the rich eisen show drew brees how
are you sir
i'm good rich and if it means anything
to you you're one of my favorites too
buddy yeah
you know what i was fishing for that i'm
not going to lie
[Laughter]
the feeling is reciprocated thank you
very much i greatly appreciate that you
know it's kind of funny we were showing
uh on game day morning on sunday morning
on our pregame show
over 7 000 days ago you and the big
house would purdue against brady
and michigan if i had walked up to you
that day and and told you
uh what what we would be talking about 7
700 days later what would you have said
to me
on that day drew oh man it would have
been the furthest thing from my
my thought process um i do remember
that game for for whatever reason pretty
vividly um
that was my my one my one game ever in
the big house in
1999. it was um
i i think you have a lot i think you'd
have a lot of fun if we went and looked
at the rosters
on on both sides um
as i recall that michigan team was
pretty stacked um
in fact i think just about the entire
offense
yes um but
i i think that the most the most uh i
think memorable thing about it was
obviously brady being on the other side
and and that was a time where
if you recall drew henson was one of the
most highly recruited oh yes
quarterbacks coming out of high school
maybe the year before
um he was also a first-round pick to the
new york yankees maybe even the first
pick of the draft
um to the new york yankees was supposed
to be kind of their apparent third
baseman
for the yankees and yet he chose to go
to michigan um to have a chance to play
michigan football
and so i think there was this this
feeling of this you know need to
obviously play him and and so he was
splitting time with brady and
i i think you could you could you could
see that it was man it was brady's team
and it was brady's leadership and um
you know brady played phenomenal that
day they beat us pretty pretty soundly
um but um but i think you felt like
man this guy what a shame he's he's
having a split time you know he deserves
to be the starter and i think at some
point
later on in that year they made him a
full-time starter and michigan just
rolled after that and
won a big bowl game against alabama that
year in the orange bowl
so i you know i i i do i do remember
pretty vividly that game and and and
kind of brady and that that his senior
season
and then just thinking to myself you
know um
you know what what are the chances that
that both of us go to the nfl and
i mean the fact that we've been able to
play 20 plus years
at the same time you know is i think
pretty remarkable yeah and of course be
one two at the top of virtually every
possible
passing metric on the all-time list and
you mentioned you know obviously drew
henson with brady and we
you know the the rest is in fact history
about being drafted 199th overall and we
make a lot about the chip on brady's
shoulder
as well as the fire that burns in inside
what about you you have a chip
if so what what is that always have a
chip
what is it always have it's here always
something to prove um
you know i i think that uh
i think that's something that's i mean
listen i um
i think what i've learned throughout my
career is this i love competition
i love to compete i love to prepare i
love sports
i mean i just love i love going out and
competing and it doesn't not just
football but anything
i've always been that way so maybe
that's just something in
my genetics um just the way god made me
but um i also have learned along the way
that
you know i'm more i'm more play and
compete and
inspired by those who have believed in
me and fostered that in me along the way
um you know so i it's not that i hold i
don't hold grudges i don't
hold any ill will for those who didn't
recruit me
or any of that stuff you know but there
is a small piece of you that knows that
there are those that
have doubted you and maybe always will
doubt you for whatever reason
and so that has that has created the
chip right it's added fuel to the fire
um but at the end of the day that's not
that's not totally what motivates me
so the here and now remarkably
after all this time there's still doubts
i'm sure you heard it earlier this year
drew and i'll place it in front of you
as i was always keen to know what you
thought about the fact that you can't
throw down the field anymore apparently
um that uh you don't look that way that
there's no
ability to push it down the field
anymore what did you think about
uh that as i'm sure maybe it did pass
your ear gate to use the michael irvin
phrase from weeks two through about five
well the first thing i'd say is you know
what what's the objective
what's the objective the objective is to
win the game right
um the objective is to score points
the objective is to take care of the
football the objective is to make the
decisions
the objective is to put everyone around
you in the best position to succeed
right so that's the all those things are
the objective
it's not to look pretty throwing the
ball down the field
so if the opportunities are there and
that's what it takes to win
then that's what we'll do um if people
defenses want to prevent you from doing
that then we'll find other ways we got a
lot of ways we'll beat you
so i would i would first of all say all
those things
and secondly i'd say who who are the
ones making those statements and do they
know anything about
football and do they know anything about
playing the quarterback position
in most cases i'd probably say they
don't so
um taking what's in front of you now
also includes michael thomas
um can you walk me through what the last
several weeks with him has been
injury-wise and obviously that couple
week period where
um he didn't play once because of
an internal matter and i'm sure that you
you would like to keep that internal but
what can you share with me about
him and and and his return and what was
going on behind the scenes to facilitate
this return
drew yeah well first off you know
you got to know mike and his mentality
and his
preparation and just his competitive
nature i mean here's a guy who
has not missed a snap i mean talking
practice games you name it like
he's a warrior and one of the most
competitive dudes i've ever been around
you know so for him to
miss any time you know obviously is
significant with the ankle injury
um so tough on him you know the first
time
somebody has to deal with something like
that you know um
and i think
i think for us as an offense a first
time we've been without him
you know since he's been here and he's
in he's been such a mainstay and he's
been such a reliable
weapon for us so you know for us to have
to make the
you know the adjustments accordingly and
then we use lose emanuel sanders you
know to covet for a couple weeks as well
you know so
so man a ton of young guys having to
step up i mean i think for a couple
games straight
four out of our five receivers were
undrafted free agents you guys have
started the season on practice squad
and yet man these guys stepped up and
and played great and did exactly what we
needed them to do and
um you know we found ways to win you
know and that's i think that's what
great teams do
um but great to get a guy like that back
i think the challenge going into the
tampa game last week with both
mike and emmanuel was you know you don't
just immediately go from not playing at
all to playing
60 snaps you know so it's there's that
there's that ramp up phase
you know with both of them and you don't
want to put too much pressure on them or
put them in a position where
you're just going to wear them down out
there again so i think i think
man mike played the perfect number of
snaps got the perfect amount of reps and
catches and you know just kind of
getting back into it and so obviously
that'll continue to ramp up and
listen mike thomas is the player that
he's always been you know and
um he's the competitor he's always been
so
it's just good to have him back so look
you know i
the question i'm about to ask you uh is
not intended for you to say anything
desp
disrespectful about tom brady because i
know how you feel about him and vice
versa
but the fact that you were able to go on
that field and perform as you did and
the team perform
as it did and a night where everybody's
tuning in to see
brady versus breeze does that have any
significance for you
drew well listen the
first off the significance is hey
they're divisional opponent right
they're a very good individual opponent
when you look at their record
um and man we're fighting for the same
thing right we're fighting for
um position in the division division
title you know
um hopefully playoffs and and beyond so
there was that significance first and
foremost
um listen um i'm not i'm not gonna lie
and say that that game carries the same
weight as every other game i mean
playing against a guy like tom brady
even though we're not
on the field at the same time
technically playing against each other
there's this heightened level of um
i think competition awareness everything
is to
just i know it takes that much more
um with everything that i need to do and
everything our offense needs to do
to compete against a guy like that who's
on the other side of the ball
um that's the way it's always been
throughout our careers
and um it's because of respect
um and admiration that that i have for
him
and and for that team and what what
they're building there so
um i mean uh
i can't say enough about our team and
the effort that we put forth and
um you know just one of those games
where you're
offensively defensively special teams it
just it all comes together for a
for a great amount of football a few
minutes left here with drew brees
on the rich eisen show and and look we
we we all know what was going on
uh back after the super bowl we saw you
in in south florida the concept about
maybe
were you gonna come back or not and then
that that remarkable instagram
photograph that you posted
along with your announcement that you
were coming back um
made it official now that we're halfway
through this season obviously anything
can happen
the rest of the season but one thing i
think we can should know for sure is
this season is
it's not going to be like any other with
fans and covet and all the craziness
going on in the world is there
part of you thinking to yourself the way
that this team is set up the way that
you are playing
that maybe there's another year that
vaccine comes
things can change and you want to go
through one more nfl season with
fans in the stands and your family all
come in and it's all good when you go
home you have to worry about passing
anything to them i mean is that is that
going through your head right now
true no i'm i'm just i'm in the moment i
mean
i really am and i can
i can say that that's really the way
it's been the last couple years
obviously this year unlike any other i
mean
i think all of us can't wait to get
beyond 2020 and
and on to you know the better times and
safer times
and you know more confident times but um
bottom line is you know we
we're tasked with playing the game of
football during all this right um
we still come to work every day and
still go through the same preparation
and
and go out and play on sundays you know
the same way now granted
it is different not having fans um i i
think we've had to adjust to that
but at the same time um you know we're
this is our this is our new normal for
the time being
we're just gonna take it one week at a
time we're gonna try to continue to
build on what
you know we put on the field last week
and there's still a lot of football left
and there's still a lot to prove and i
still think we have a lot of improvement
as a team so living in the moment right
now you haven't even thought for
yourself this could be the last one so
let me live in the moment more
or whatever you know where i'm driving
out here i mean
i don't think i can live in the moment
anymore that that's what i'm i'm just
i'm really really just being in the
present and taking it i just
the same mindset i've had the last
couple of years i mean honestly i
haven't taken any year for granted
um since 2017 for that matter
i've looked at each year like this could
be my last and so i'm going to treat it
as such so then i guess was there any
truth to the rumor that you were
thinking that this was it and
you were you were ready to go and then
just last second maybe
peyton you know sean twisted your arm a
little bit is there any truth to that
about coming back no i mean i took i
took i took the necessary time
i took the necessary time to consider
everything and just
i didn't want to rush to any decisions
either way um
and i think that's that's really the way
it's been the last couple years i think
there's just more attention on it now
than there ever has been before because
you know
41 years old and i guess more towards
the end of my career than i am in the
beginning
so um before i let you go let's talk
about your foundation
um drew brees.com the drew brees
foundation what is going on
with it and how can people support with
what you and brittany are doing
yeah well we're um first off we take as
much pride in what we do
through our foundations we do anything
um
and it's been obviously a very
tumultuous year
um but starting from the beginning of
this year you know that was actually
part of
the decision making process my wife and
i were coming back for this year we said
you know what i just get the feeling
that this year is going to be
about much more than just football and
certainly it has in so many ways
but with the start of it with covid and
our five million dollar commitment
to the state of louisiana to fund meal
programs to help take care of people
that have been furloughed
laid off for their jobs the last thing
we wanted anybody in the state of
louisiana to feel is that they couldn't
care for their families and feed their
families and so um
we undertook a huge meal program with
second harvest food bank and the other
four food banks in the state and we've
been able to distribute
more than a million meals throughout the
state in that amount of time we also
made another 5 million
commitment um in partnership with
ochsner health systems which is the
biggest health
care group in the state to build 13
health care facilities both primary care
and specialty care
and underserved communities to to bring
health care
to those that otherwise wouldn't be able
to get it
to bridge that equality gap so we're
very proud of that 10 million dollar
commitment all the way around and
there's more to come
there's still a lot of work to do but we
love the state we love
our community we love the people and
we want to continue to give back what
what we've had the opportunity to do
bree's dream foundation again at
drewbreeze.com i got two more for you
if you could choose the game of somebody
24 and younger
at your position that you could have
that you would want you've done it all
but i'm just talking about
somebody that the position 24 and
younger which means i'm throwing my
homes out
so who would that be drew brees
so you're you're saying i basically have
to i'm picking a quarterback who's 24
and younger than that yes
whose skill set you're like wow that
that kid is something else
i would choose
um baker um josh allen
these kids what do you got shoot
i only choose one yeah i know right
um kyla murray's in that mix too right
he is that listen all those guys are
studs
um i'm i i've been
i haven't had a chance to see a ton of
two of but obviously he only has two
starts under his belt but man
i think what i've seen looks really
impressive i think everybody's excited
to see more
more of you him lamar jackson is a skill
set that you just kind of shake your
head at
like man this guy's ability to throw the
football run the football
and he's a threat wherever he is on the
field
i don't know i josh allen i think his
his uh his rise here his development
over the last
from last year to this year um has been
extremely impressive too and borrow i
mean you had a front row seat to his 60
touchdowns
i've never seen i've never seen a guy
have the college season that burrow had
um and i feel like yeah i mean that was
right in our backyard right at the road
in baton rouge i was at the national
championship game
um kind of had some insight into into
that because joe brady
his offensive coordinators now the
panthers was with us as a
offensive assistant for a couple years
so they were running our system so it's
funny i'd watch
games and i'd text joe brady and be like
hey you just ran such and such
you know and he'd laugh text back so
yeah i mean i don't know you can't
choose one all those guys are studs they
sure
are all right and last one for you you
know we started saying you're a sports
fan and i know
uh you love golf um so it's masters week
amazingly because of the craziness of
the world
uh in november who what do you who do
you think what do you
who do you think is going to take the
green jacket i'm here with tayson hill
right now
we're both golf fans okay so let's get a
consensus
let's get a consensus oh he says he's
looking for a tiger repeat that's what
he's looking for huh well we all are
right
i mean my gosh what about the shambo dj
yeah we feel like dj dj's strong
contender
deshambo think about this drew you can
alright you can have
those are our top three right there can
we can we name can we give a top three
absolutely that's
just think about this drew you're you're
you're
you're you got the ball on on your own
goal line and you're looking down the
field 100 yards
think about that de chambeau can hit it
four times as long with a golf ball i
mean that's insane
what's going on yeah well he's built
he's built like a linebacker he is he
like takes him over here
so who's got the best stick in the nfl i
know that was one once upon a time you
were you were looking to find that
individual with a with a tournament that
we actually put on nfl network here's
an nfl i remember that um yeah who do
you think
now that romo is in the booth do you
know you got a sense yeah
you know what um i don't know give me
give me some names
i don't know i mean i'm assuming it's
gonna be i'm out of the golf mix i'm
i've i transitioned from golf to the
parenting mix and and now i'm trying to
make my way back to the golf course
i love it i'm sorry i'm so i'm sure you
saw brady go out there
with uh peyton you know and tiger and
phil and then barkley giving him all
sorts of crap like it's easy to do
you know i mean i saw that a couple
months yeah here's a
i'll take i'll take barkley and we'll
we'll take on anybody
okay i like it very good uh hey drew
appreciate the call
um and uh my best to your wife and your
family
and uh let's do this again uh down the
road uh congrats on the big win sunday
night being the one seed
uh moving into the next half of the
season thanks to call of duty
thanks rich great talking man right back
at you that's drew brees drewbreeze.com
for the
breeze dream foundation hey you watched
all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here